-The last time we talked was
Before "Avengers: Endgame"
came out.
And that went on to be
the biggest movie
in the whole wide world ever.
-Right, right, right, right.
-Yeah, giant.
And then, I was reading
something about you
and about, you know,
"Black Panther."
And somewhere in the thing,
it said that you auditioned for
a different superhero
for Marvel at first.
-I did. Drax, yeah, yeah.
-You auditioned for Drax?
-Yeah, weirdly enough, yeah.
-From "Guardians."
-Let me just show everyone
who -- This is --
[ Laughter ]
This is Drax.
-Batista.
-Yeah, so you auditioned
for that?
-I did. I did.
You know, it's about
going and playing.
I didn't think
I was gonna get it.
And it's weird too, because it's
a testament, I think,
to Marvel because after each
film, you know --
"Ant-Man" has a different tone
and feeling.
We didn't know
what that was gonna be.
We didn't know what "Guardians"
was gonna be.
So I didn't know what it was.
And I only had
a few pages at that time.
So it was just good
to come in and play
to see what they did with it.
-And they remembered you
from that and they go,
"Oh, we got to put him --
we have a role for him,
but we don't want to tell him"?
-Well, sometimes, that's the way
it works as an actor.
You go in knowing
you're not gonna get it,
but you're meeting the people
that, you know,
they might be like,
"He's not this,
but we'll put him in
this other thing."
So I feel like that was one of
the moments when they were like,
"Hey, we could use him later."
-And I know
during the interview for --
-Sarah Finn, casting director.
-Is that who did that?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I love giving shout-outs
to casting directors.
-Sarah Finn, Sarah Finn.
-Sarah Finn, good job, Sarah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She did a great job, obviously.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Really worked well.
I loved your interviews that you
were doing during "Endgame"
because you had
to give interviews saying that
you were in the movie, but you
didn't want to spoil anything.
That's the way it works with
Marvel movies.
They don't really want you
to talk about much.
Talk about, you know, they say,
"Watch, go see our movie,
but we can't spoil anything."
And you did something in your
interviews that made me laugh.
I think we showed it
on the show once.
But I want to show it to you
while you're here.
Here's Chadwick Boseman not
spoiling "Avengers: Endgame."
Take a look at this.
-People are, like, ready to see
this movie.
They're buying the tickets.
It's nuts.
I mean, how does
that feel to know
that they love this film
so much?
-It's great, but I'm dead.
[ Laughter ]
So I can't answer any questions
about that.
-Oh, okay.
So you don't want to give us
a spoiler or anything like that?
-I'm dead.
-What about "Black Panther 2"?
Anything?
-I'm dead.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, man.
-It made us laugh.
We showed it on the show.
We loved it. It made me laugh.
-It was the most fun
doing that, actually.
[ Laughter ]
-Where did you come up with,
"I'm dead"?
-Well, it was the first time
I had done press, you know,
in a minute since we shot it.
And so I was like,
"You know what?
I can make this real easy.
I can just come out
and say, 'I'm dead.'"
It's that simple.
-Because you did die or -- Yeah.
-Yeah, and the funny thing about
it is, you coming in --
I didn't even know I was
gonna die that day.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, a lot of us, so today --
You don't have all the script
at times, you know,
because of their secret,
secretive about stuff.
-And you film all different
endings and stuff.
-Yeah. Well, you have
different scripts.
You have different scripts,
you know, like different --
to throw people off.
-Wow. What are you gonna do?
Because you're filming
"Black Panther 2" now.
You have all this time.
You can't just tell everyone
you're dead.
-You know what?
I don't know what it is --
what it's gonna be this time,
but I'll come up with something.
-Yeah, yeah, you are.
-I got to do it tonight
before we do the premiere,
because I'm on
the red carpet tonight.
-Oh, that's right.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you can be like,
"I'm back."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"I'm back."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I want to talk about
"21 Bridges."
Congrats on this thing.
-Thank you.
-How did you get involved with
this movie?
-Well, I was dead...
[ Laughter ]
-This is unbelievable.
-...after "Infinity War,"
and the Russo brothers came to
me at the premiere after-party.
-Did a great job, yeah.
-Yeah, I think it was
a consolation.
You're dead, so let me bring you
another movie.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And so, yeah, you know,
they were like,
"We think you're perfect for
this role."
And then I met Brian Kirk,
the director.
I was like, "We're going to be
a great collaborator."
And we decided to produce it.
-It's a good movie.
It's very -- I like the premise.
There's a lot of action.
But basically set it up
for everybody.
The idea is --
-Eight cops are killed.
I'm an NYPD detective
who's known for, you know,
tracking down cop killers.
And so I shut down
the city of Manhattan,
like, all of the entryways into
it, including the 21 bridges,
so that we can trap
the offenders and catch them.
-They're stuck on --
-Stuck on the island.
-Stuck on Manhattan.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you said 21 bridges.
I didn't know there was
21 bridges around Manhattan.
-I didn't either.
Actually, when we started, the
script was called "17 Bridges."
[ Laughter ]
No, they didn't build
four bridges but, you know,
I'm about to do
a speech about the 21 bridges.
And I was like --
about the 17 bridges --
and they're like,
"We might have got it wrong.
We might have got it wrong."
[ Laughter ]
-Right, yeah. We got to recount.
-They were gonna
rename the movie.
"If we can't figure it out,
let's call the movie
'Lockdown.'"
[ Laughter ]
-"Let's not even
mention bridges.
We have to talk about bridges."
-I was like,
"Figure this out for me."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. 21 bridges.